و CLA سيباستيان من CNN تتابع
التطورات وهي تنضم إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة من
لندن، صباح الخير لك CLA، لذلك في
أعقاب هذه الضربة المشتركة بين الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة على
اليمن، قامت الولايات المتحدة
بإسقاط طائرة أخرى بدون طيار للحوثيين في
البحر الأحمر، ما هو الأبيض؟  مجلس النواب
يقول عن انتقام محتمل من قبل
الحوثيين نعم، إنهم يقولون إنه
جزء كبير من الحسابات هنا، انظر إلى
السياق أه أن الولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها يقولون إن ما
يفعلونه هو ضربات جراحية محددة للغاية
مصممة من أجل وأنا  اقتباس يعطل
ويقلل من قدرة الحكومتين على
تعريض الشحن البحري في البحر الأحمر للخطر، ولكن على
الجانب الفيليب لدينا إيران التي تعد
بالطبع الداعم الرئيسي ليس فقط
للحويين ولكن أيضًا لحزب الله وحماس الذين
يحاولون استغلال هذا الوضع بالإضافة إلى
بالطبع  الصراع في غزة بشكل
عام أه لحشد حلفائها من
النوع الخاص من الوكلاء في المنطقة
ضد الرؤية الأمريكية للشرق
الأوسط ضد الدور الأمريكي في تلك المنطقة كما هو الحال
وفقًا
لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية الإيرانية، أجرى الرئيس RI دعوة
الأحد مع رئيس
المجلس السياسي الأعلى هوي الذي قال فيه إن
الضربات الأمريكية على اليمن تكشف عن
طبيعتها العدوانية في نفس الوقت
لدينا خطاب تلفزيوني لزعيم حزب الله
حسن نزالا أيضا خلال نهاية الأسبوع أه
أيضا يهاجم أمريكا أه
لضرباتها في اليمن، لذا فإنك
تخبرك حقًا بما تحتاج إلى معرفته هنا، لذا
استمع في هذا السياق إلى جون
كيربي المتحدث باسم مجلس الأمن القومي الأمريكي
على شبكة سي بي إس يوم
الأحد، وأعتقد أنه سيكون من العبث أن
نعتقد أن هناك  لا يمكن أو لا يمكن أن
يكون هناك نوع من الضربة الانتقامية من قبل
السكان، فنحن نراقب هذا عن
كثب، لقد اتخذنا
الاحتياطات اللازمة في
المنطقة للتأكد من أننا مستعدون
لذلك إذا  كان من المفترض أن تحدث هذه الضربات
كان القصد منها تعطيل وإضعاف
قدرتهم على تنفيذ هذه الضربات
أم ولذلك نعتقد أنه كان لدينا
تأثير جيد على أننا لا نزال نقيم أه
تقييم أضرار المعركة لتلك
الضربات ولكن نعتقد أنه كان لدينا
تأثير جيد  لذلك ما زالوا يحاولون
معرفة مدى فعالية هذه الضربات،
واتضح بالطبع أنه بينما كان
يتحدث قبل ساعتين فقط،
كانت الولايات المتحدة قد انتهت للتو من
إسقاط
صاروخ كروز مضاد للسفن أطلقه الحوثيون  مناطق
أه في اليمن لذلك انظر هذا لا يزال
مستمرا قال هناك احتمال أه للمزيد
هنا ومن الواضح أن هذا
عمل موازنة أه للولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها لمحاولة ردع الحوثيين
لمحاولة إضعاف قدرتهم على تعطيل
هذا الأمر الحاسم  الشحن أه
الممر المائي في البحر الأحمر مع
تجنب المزيد من التصعيد أيضا نظرا لما
نسمعه من إيران
روزماري